this video is sponsored by brilliant
today i need to run an errand and then
go home so come with me on the bike
if any of you been wondering how the
bike's been getting on very well it's
been about 850 kilometers on it
according to the odometer in just less
than a year
and
i think the only issue i've had in that
entire time has been one flat which
you know it's a bike but i've been
extraordinarily happy with it i think
i'd like to do another video on the bike
actually or electric bikes in general
let me know in the comments
what you'd like to see me talk about in
that video because it's literally my
most searched video and
felt like i feel like i could do more
hi i'm here to pick up some keys oh sure
yes it was
you've seen the title you know what this
video is about we bought a house
t-pose to establish dominance
[Music]
i'm aware of how silly this looks
after 13 years of living in different
places for one year two years one year
six months three months two years one
year one year one year one year one year
and one year
we finally bought a house we bought a
house and
you've paid for it like 50 of the
mortgage of this property comes from
pixar girl having a normal productive
member of society job and 50 comes from
me making youtube videos it comes from
this
and that's wild
we could just leave it here
no
all
right so this video is trying to do
three things first of all and this is a
little old-fashioned i think for science
youtube at least
it's trying to commemorate this life
event you know this is up there with
finishing the phd or finishing at oxford
this is this is huge we bought a house
secondly and much more importantly this
is trying to say thank you because
if you've watched a video of mine if
you've signed up with a sponsor if you
clicked on an affiliate link if you
support me at patreon.com forward slash
simonox fizz
you've paid for a bit of this house it's
not an exaggeration you see this
cupboard door
dan hanvy paid for that via patreon
actually
he supported me for so long he's
literally probably paid for this kitchen
at this point this brick was bought by
colonist catsy on twitch.tv4
simon clark
love this tank and lastly and this is
related
i wanted to take this opportunity to
reflect on how far this community and
this channel has come looking back on my
old videos i honestly wonder why anyone
ever watched them let alone subscribed
and said they wanted to watch more
this channel has been on a real journey
people who found me relatively recently
may not be aware that this channel was
originally a vlog channel i vlogged my
experience studying at the university of
oxford as a state school student and
eventually started vlogging my
experience studying for my phd at exeter
there will be some people in the
comments and please do shout out if this
is you who have been around since the
oxford days and
thank you so much because i do not
understand why he subscribed those
videos were not good since i submitted
my thesis in late 2017 i've been making
educational and hopefully entertaining
videos most weeks and there have been so
many incredible experiences along the
way i've driven a mars rover written an
episode of star trek been to korea and
sweden ran some half marathons and
published a book
i've met so many amazing interesting
people and have made some extraordinary
new friendships but the only reason i've
been able to do all of this is because
of you watching this video right now the
first video on this channel was filmed
by an old camera perched on a stack of
dvds and my copy of pharaoh the last
videos i partly filmed in the old house
were about the quest to understand life
on mars and dark matter in a lab a
kilometer below the earth's surface that
i got to visit thanks to people like you
seeing my videos on youtube and choosing
to watch them and supporting me on and
off the platform you've allowed me to
make more and more ambitious content
upgrade my gear take on an employee and
honestly live out some of my dreams it
is a privilege to be able to do this job
and i never forget that fact i
am so lucky to have a job where i just
make videos about stuff i find
interesting i research something write a
script make a video and somehow
that ended up with me being able to
afford a place
for pixar and i to
to call our own i recognize how
privileged i am to do this and
i'm incredibly thankful to you as a
community for making this possible i
thank you a million times i don't know
how to express it as you may have been
able to turn on the background of a lot
of these shots we've literally just
moved into the house we've barely begun
unpacking so
lots to do here lots of things that we
want to do to put our stamp on it and
there's some really exciting times ahead
as is also the case for this channel
lots of plans more specifically i'm
currently in a temporary setup here in
our dining room whilst we do some work
to the upstairs where i'm going to have
an office eventually however i would
like to move out and actually get my own
studio and finally have a bit of
separation between work and life and
that will also allow me to make some
more ambitious content and have a set
aside space that i can do longer term
projects with which
i'm really excited for i also have plans
to expand where i'm putting content so
recently the patreon has actually been
getting a lot more love luke has done a
fantastic job of putting together a
behind the scenes vlog of every month so
that was that's been the case last month
it's gonna be the case this month i'm
not quite sure how that's gonna gel with
doing a vloggy type thing for this
that's a bridge we'll just have to cross
when we come to it but if you do sign up
as a patreon you get access to that
behind the scenes blog and also there's
some more exclusive content planned for
the patreon in the future so if you're
not already that's a great place to
support this channel and help me make
more videos i also have a second channel
which some of you may not be aware of
simon clark errata which is basically
where i put stuff that i would like to
put on the main channel but i just don't
think it would quite fit and it's a
place for me to experiment a bit more
and i've got some fun video ideas for
there too that i'm going to be editing
over the next
couple of months so if you're not
subscribed to that check it out that's
going to be a place for me to do some
experimenting and there's a bunch of
plans for content going in other places
which i can't talk about yet because
nothing's concrete but
keep an eye on my twitter and my
instagram i will post when stuff
comes out when i can talk about it all
this is to say that this is a really
exciting time for me as a human being
you know we've got the new house there's
lots of stuff changing at the moment
we're getting married in a couple of
months
but also this is a very exciting time
for you as a member of this community
because whether you're here for the
science type content or the vloggy type
content or if you just want to see me
put my style on lots of different kinds
of projects
there's going to be something for you in
the coming months so thank you so much
for everything that you've done so far
and for making this possible
but i do now have a mortgage to pay so
if you could stick around i'd really
really appreciate it there is however an
extra group of people that i need to say
a very special thank you to and those
are the people who have sponsored this
youtube channel for the longest time
believe it or not brilliant have put up
with my nonsense since
2017 and they very kindly agreed to
sponsor this video as well brilliant is
of course the perfect companion to this
channel because they're all about
learning subjects and maths science and
computer science in a fun interactive
way which is kind of what i'm trying to
do with these videos with their
beautifully illustrated website and app
you can challenge yourself by learning
about new subjects or brushing up on old
ones with courses on everything from
electricity to infinity and beyond and
with their learning pass you have a road
map to take your understanding of a
subject from zero to hero via expertly
written interactive exercises learning
more about physics and mathematics has
allowed me to undertake some incredible
projects on this channel and maybe it
will do the same for you too start for
free by signing up at brilliant.org
simon clark and the first 200 people to
do so will get 20 off a premium annual
subscription thanks so much to brilliant
for sponsoring this video and for being
such a good friend to this channel
thank you so much for watching the video
right the way to the end and thank you
for bearing with me during this kind of
two-week period where we've been living
out of boxes and i've not had access to
all my equipment next week hopefully
service will resume as usual with a
science video essay in the meantime
here's some recommended viewing next and
if you're not already subscribed you can
check that out down there
thank you again for watching i'll see
you in the next one